[Música]
i
hola y bienvenidos a europa hoy el
programa de actualidad europea de france
24 en español yo soy esther herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy hablamos de la ampliación de la
unión europea será ucrania algún día un
país miembro que ocurrirá con el resto
de países candidatos todo esto lo
hablamos con nuestros invitados de hoy
pero antes hacemos un breve repaso sobre
la ampliación de la unión europea la
unión europea se creó en
1958 por seis países -francia alemania
bélgica países bajos luxemburgo e italia
con la idea de que si los países están
unidos económicamente más estrechos
serán sus lazos y más difícil que se
libre una guerra entre ellos entre los
años 70 y 90 el proceso de ampliación
fue lento entraron 9 países más entre
ellos reino unido españa y finlandia
durante una década de la unión europea
se mantuvo con 15 países pero a
principios de los años 2000 se hizo la
gran ampliación hacia el este entraron
12 países casi todos los antiguos
soviéticos en 2013 entró el último
croacia ahora continúan esperando como
candidatos albania macedonia del norte
serbia montenegro y turquía que lleva
más de 20 años en negociaciones a la
espera de convertirse en candidatos está
en bosnia y kosovo y más recientemente
moldavia georgia y ucrania este último
lo solicitó tras la invasión de rusia y
se espera que antes del verano los
capitales aprueben en soledad el estatus
de candidato
y para hablar de esta ampliación de la
unión europea contamos con la
eurodiputada de la izquierda europea y
de ahí había nueva bienvenida ido ya que
tal encanta de estar aquí y con el
eurodiputado del grupo socialdemócrata
javi lópez bienvenidos javi bienvenido a
los dos de nuevo me gustaría empezar con
una pregunta para los dos y
precisamente vamos a ver hay una
posibilidad real de que la unión europea
pueda ampliarse en un futuro cercano
javi
se necesita tiempo para el proceso de
ampliación y además tenemos a países en
cola especialmente los balcanes en el
2020 abrimos las conversaciones con
macedonia tenemos también el caso de
albania países donde se puede avanzar
pero sabemos que ese proceso es un
proceso lento lo que yo creo es muy
relevante tanto para los balcanes como
para el caso de ucrania es que seamos
capaces desde la unión europea de
generar la expectativa y el horizonte
político en términos positivos y de
incentivos que permita hacer reformas
con esos países asentar sus democracias
y también consolidar sus economías y al
mismo tiempo todo esta capacidad de
irradiación y voluntad de sumarse a la
unión es un buen recordatorio de que la
unión europea es continuada viendo hoy a
ojos de muchos aún teniendo muchos
problemas durante la última década como
un espacio de estabilidad y prosperidad
y seguridad de paz que atrae a nuestro
alrededor así que yo creo que también
nos debiera de permitir ahora también a
rebufo del día de europa que valoramos
el espacio que hemos construido y que
continuamos teniendo la puerta abierta
para aquellos que asomarse ido ya
bueno como decía javi no no es menor que
un país decida unirse al proyecto de la
unión europea no es una cosa menor y
tiene que hacerse con tiempo y con
responsabilidad y en ese sentido bueno
por supuesto quedan en europea está
abierta a esas ampliaciones que hayan
venido ocurriendo pero también nosotros
tenemos la responsabilidad de hacer un
análisis sobre qué ha ocurrido con las
últimas ampliaciones y en este momento
qué celebrábamos ayer el día de europa y
que tenemos también encima de la mesa la
conferencia de europa algo que creo que
es muy importante esa reflexión sobre
qué es el europeo que significa ser la
ciudadanía europea y bajo mi punto de
vista ser europeo tiene que significar
un conjunto de derechos un conjunto de
libertades y un conjunto de compromisos
y en ese sentido yo creo que hay que
seguir trabajando avanzando con
responsabilidad respetando esos procesos
que los países existan esos compromisos
esas reformas y poder definir cuál es
ese proyecto europeo conjunto sin
ninguna duda
se espera que en junio la comisión
europea tenga listo su informe sobre si
acepta o no a ucrania como país
candidato hay que darle un plan y este
estatus porque está el primero hay que
ser candidato y luego empieza ya el
proceso como tal de adhesión hay que
darle este estatus si vamos de forma
clara yo creo que es absolutamente
necesario que en una situación actual
las circunstancias actuales se construya
este horizonte político para ucrania que
además ha demostrado durante los últimos
años su voluntad de forma firme y clara
de formar parte del club comunitario y
de hecho es hoy la razón principal por
la que está pagando un altísimo precio
en forma de una agresión militar
de rusia hemos tenido debates durante
los últimos meses alrededor de la otan y
en la membresía la otan y la ampliación
al este pero de hecho en ucrania los
problemas derivados de la influencia
rusa durante los últimos años vienen por
la voluntad en el año 2014 de firmar un
acuerdo a asociación con la unión
europea ese es el 'kilómetro cero' es
que yo creo que es claro que ha mostrado
una voluntad inquebrantable
eso también va unido a la necesidad del
país de que haga reformas combate a la
corrupción asegure el estado de derecho
a la separación de poderes y cumpla con
unos criterios que deben ser muy
exigentes en todas estas materias de
libertades y de estabilidad económica
que están recogidos en los criterios de
copenhague y es un camino largo que
además también va a requerir de
acompañamiento e inversiones en el caso
de ucrania pero el primer paso es un
paso necesario para dar para que
decidamos entre todos en este caso el
consejo europeo que es un país candidato
y se ha tratado como tal pero no puede
creer eso algún tipo de frustraciones
por ejemplo albania tardó 5 años por
ejemplo en ser país candidato en cambio
se le otorgan muy poco tiempo a ucrania
qué mensaje se le puede dar esto a los
balcanes no puede generar frustraciones
que yo creo que él crea el proceso no se
puede tener un trato diferencial en el
caso de ucrania
el proceso es largo como bien se ha
comentado de hecho le está el secretario
general del pd había hecho unos cálculos
que decía si cumpliéramos todos los
procedimientos y los calendarios y
admitir amos en julio a ucrania como
país candidato podría entrar en la unión
europea en el 2036 para hacer uno
digamos un dibujo sobre eso así que aún
admitiendo como candidato a ucrania se
requeriría un proceso largo que no
requiere que que no se puede hacer de
forma excepcional pero sí que construir
ese horizonte político sobre el que
también a ucrania ha demostrado tanta
voluntad tanta voluntad por formar parte
de la unión y luego recordando en el
caso de macedonia a principios de siglo
se le otorgó el estatus de país
candidato y hasta el 2020 no empezaron
las conversaciones así que es un proceso
largo
pero que requiere de acompañamiento de
exigencia en términos democráticos
separación de poderes estabilidad
económica pero al mismo tiempo con esta
puerta abierta que yo creo que genera
incentivos positivos a nuestra vecindad
especialmente aquella que quiere formar
parte idoia crees que ucrania debería
ser miembro bueno yo creo que como
venimos diciendo entrar dentro del
proceso de la unión euro de la unión
europea es un proceso muy serio y
riguroso sí mismo y yo creo que lo
importante en primer lugar es tener esa
igualdad de oportunidades de trabajo y
de proceso en todo lo que tiene que ver
en nuestra política exterior y de iu de
vecindad
yo creo que lo que la unión europea
tiene que hacer con ucrania es poner
ahora mismo todo su esfuerzo y todos sus
recursos en acabar cuanto antes con la
invasión criminal que está sufriendo de
ucrania el proceso de candidato es un
buen gesto político y yo creo que es un
mensaje también político pero creo que
tenemos que también ser responsables y
honestos por un lado en ser conscientes
de que es un proceso que es largo que no
va a ser inmediato y en segundo lugar
que para poder llevarse a cabo un país
tiene que tener control sobre sobre su
soberanía y hoy ucrania es un país
invadido con lo cual no tiene control
sobre su soberanía tal como lo define el
propio derecho
internacional por tanto yo creo que
también en eso tenemos que ser
responsables honestos y ser y ser
capaces de entender lo que es un gesto
político pero también en cuál tiene que
ser nuestra prioridad hoy como europeos
que tiene que ser poner todos los
recursos y capacidades por acabar con
esa invasión y llegar a un acuerdo
cuanto antes para que esta guerra
termine y sus consecuencias terminen
también para todos y para todas
de las preocupaciones que que algunos
países
ya miembros han alertado es que a menudo
se dice que la ampliación al este en el
2004 fue un error que se hizo de prisa
que se hizo corriendo por esta necesidad
de romper definitivamente con el telón
de acero fue un error esta ampliación yo
no lo creo de verdad que fuera un error
yo creo que es un análisis un tanto
simplista pero sí que podemos sacar
algunas reflexiones y conclusiones y
también necesidades de cambio de lo que
fue la ampliación al este especialmente
viendo hoy los problemas que existen en
materia de estado de derecho en algunos
países como hungría y polonia la unión
europea se ha demostrado eficaz a la
hora de cambiar a los países que quieren
formar parte del club no va a hacer
pasar por el aro digamos democrático y
de exigencia institucional y también
económica para formar parte de la unión
europea esos criterios de copenhague que
antes hacíamos referencia pero nos hemos
demostrado durante los últimos años y
creo que es evidente menos eficaces a la
hora de alertar y especialmente para
procesos de carácter autoritario que se
viven una vez estás dentro del club
tiene hoy menos herramientas la unión
europea para los que forman parte de la
unión para parar los pies ante esas
derivas de carácter autoritario que para
asegurar y garantizar la democracia
aquellos que quieren entrar por eso es
necesario hacer cambios y por eso hoy
aquí estamos discutiendo poner en marcha
por ejemplo el reglamento que tiene que
ver con la financiación de recursos
europeos y de estado de derecho parar de
financiar a países con recursos europeos
que están incumpliendo el estado de
derecho y poner en marcha mecanismos que
sean realmente eficaces ante lo que
están pasando en algunos lugares que es
enormemente preocupante además lugares
gobernados por la nueva derecha radical
en el este de europa
idoia antes comentaba sobre esta
ampliación del este bueno
yo creo que
como decíamos antes estamos ahora mismo
en un proceso de mirarnos al espejo
dentro de la unión europea y de decidir
qué es lo que somos y qué es lo que
queremos ser evidentemente aunque todos
hagamos referencia en el día de europa
los valores fundacionales de europa
todos también sabemos que el principio
del proyecto europeo fue una unión y de
alguna manera protege protegerse
económicamente para salvaguardarnos
también ese mercado común que diese
mayores posibilidades de aguante en un
momento tan convulso eso ha ido
progresando y hoy en día europa tenemos
un lugar de derechos de libertades que
muchas veces están en juego y están en
peligro en ese sentido y yo creo que es
esencial que hagamos ese análisis de qué
queremos hacer con el proyecto europeo y
quién entra a ese club europeo como
decimos si está dispuesto a
comprometerse con el mismo hoy hemos
vivido como en hungría y en polonia se
persiguen los derechos lgtb y no unos
valores fundamentales de la unión
europea y eso nos tiene que hacer
replantearnos de esas adhesiones como
las estamos haciendo y para ello se está
poniendo en marcha por muchas de las
herramientas que también javier
comentaban pues muchísimas gracias a los
dos lamentablemente ya nos hemos quedado
sin tiempo pero volveremos a la cuestión
de la ampliación a ustedes les esperamos
en el próximo programa de europa hoy
gracias por ver france24 en español